c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
michel mr c'est à vous à bayonne michel
vous allez rire d'un symbole breton ou
alors on va rappeler le défi jean michel
mr a dit qu'elle est arrivée à la mer il
arrivait à faire peur 10 x 10 shows une
corde associé à 10,1 à d'accord disent
oui dis arrêtez vas-y mon discours
il faut pas que ça dure si vous y
arrivez j'embrasse matthieu delormeau
si vous n'y arrivez pas vous embrasser
matthieu delormeau mais goulûment
attention c'est parti
3 il ya marie elle n'a pas du tout envie
de faire bien
m
papa comme ça non vélo
[Applaudissements]
c'est que dalle
et non c'est comme moi c'est fait c'est
comme ça oui j'ai bien qu'arrêté petit
sud a dit je n'ai pas mes pieds joints
dans les choux quoi on va voir mais j'ai
match entre message tennis à s'offrir la
corde
tu peux le faire chez hopper regardez je
suis crevé à deux c'est plutôt d'accord
la chaussure voilà comme ça les regarde
regardez regardez vous faites vais faire
la même chose voilà allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
mamadou
e
auj
lors du souper
ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
arrêtez arrêtez
l'oubli alors et
mais chez les jeunes
les shérifs c'est d'aller voir notre
volonté gens me revient mon chéri robert
revient dignement dignement sa part été
gourmand est arrivé au maire mais assez
joli
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui bravo bravo au mit c'est
quelque chose à cacher quelque chose la
mono frire j'aurai toujours à sur moi
c'est le première fois que je vois zisis
auteurs humain j'avais vu merci